e
e e
good afternoon everyone and welcome to
the house committee on Health and Human
Services and elderly Affairs we have a
couple of bills to consider an executive
session this afternoon and then we'll be
considering a couple of Senate bills
that uh We've we've heard back from the
the I'm not supposed to use that word am
I from the other body uh couple of bills
that we've received from the other body
with a couple of amendments to them uh
before we get into any of that though I
would ask you to please join me in the
Pledge of
Allegiance I pledge of allegiance to the
flag of the United States of America to
the
republ one nation under God indivisible
liberty and justice for
thank you
everyone okay I'm going to open this
executive session and uh the first bill
to be considered is house uh excuse me
Senate Bill
458 and uh representative merchant do
you have a
motion yes I do Mr chair I make a motion
to interim study and my Ral for making
the motion inter study in let's get a
second thank reprentative Le on seconds
go ahead so my rationale for inm study
was in talking with the pharmacy board
and also talking with the director of op
PLC the clinic chose um a different
route um they went down through phys
dispensing to expand it and that was
what the declaratory ruling was all
about if they had gone to the board
asking for a pharmacy permit initially
they would have been granted one so at
this point in time based upon the
president of the board based upon the op
PLC director saying the board has the
authority currently to issue a permit so
they could dispense that route there's
no need for the bill however I also have
concern that I don't want the board
dragging its feet along with oplc with
rulemaking because I want this to go
forward as quickly and exped
expeditiously as we possibly can so
therefore my recommendation to the
committee is interim
study okay representative Lan did you
want to speak to you a second um yes
thank you Mr chairman um I appreciate
all the work that's gone into this and I
believe that an interim study would will
allow us to follow up and see make sure
that a they understand how important it
is in order to get these rules set and
then also to follow up and make sure
that they're far enough along in the
process that we don't need to suggest
actual legislation to um follow up and
and and ensure this happens I would be
I'm hopeful that they'll already have
rules written and they already have
what's necessary in place uh by the time
we need to write the report for interim
study and um I believe that this is a
good solution to get to where we need to
be so I support this motion okay thank
you any other
discussion seeing no other discussion
okay motions interim study on Senate
Bill 458 I'll ask cler to
call Representative Leon
yes representative
lelis
yes clerk votes yes representative
kofalt yes representative mlan
yes representative PL yes representative
Melvin yes representative Nagel yes
representative POF yes representative
Weber yes representative McKay yes
representative frus
yes representative Canon
yes representative n upam
yes representative Shapiro yes
representative Merchant yes
representative Murphy
yes representative Hammer yes
representative TZ yes and representative
McDonald yes 20 to zero motion passes
okay if there is no objection we'll put
that on the consent
calendar and Mr chair yes the committee
report when is that du uh well today's
the to borrow is the line
right they're supposed to be in today by
noon okay today by noon so we missed
that yeah okay next week no no it's the
last week it has to be in as soon as you
can get I'll write it
now so so this afternoon you'd like them
this
afternoon oh okay well that's this
afternoon
okay yesterday is too late yeah right uh
okay um and again interim study reports
have to be done by October 25th I think
we've got plenty of time for those but
um um that's that's the deadline for
those okay moving along um the next up
is s sp505 and representative Leon you
have an amendment I understand uh yes
I'll pass this
around although you know what I'm still
I'm not actually I can take it back I'm
not sure that this is actually written
correctly um
we just forget about the amendment I'm
not sure that it's quite quite
right
okay representative L did you want to
make a motion on this or no I'd like
somebody else to make it okay all right
do I have a motion on S
sp505 representative mlan did you want
to make a
motion not without the amendment
that representative Weber I would move
on to pass on the original bill can
representative Weber moves out to pass
on SP sp505 is there a second second
representative McKay seconds
representative Weber would you like to
speak to your
motion
just
up thank you
as we've all been grappling about what
to do with these
synthetic uh derivatives of
hemp and um I appreciate that
representative Leon made a valiant
effort to try and put a
sensible way of addressing it into the
statute and I do recognize that they
problems with the way things are now
because they come into the state
unregulated or they come into the state
from other places where they are not
regulated but um the the bill as it came
to us will repeal the repeal of the
prohibition which gets us back to
keeping these prohibited and that at
least if we find that there are problems
gives um law enforcement some authority
to to deal with them and I think that
for the moment with everything in the
state of flux that's the way we should
keep things uh so I'm hoping that you
will support an not to pass
motion okay thank you other discussion
representative McKay did you want to
comment on your second or no
representative of PL uh thank you uh
representative Weber for your
explanation because a repeal of a repeal
confused me now I understand what it
does representative
palazov thank you Mr chair uh I will be
voting against each time uh we announce
a drug V on a certain drug it's being
replaced by more dangerous drug and
second uh like one of the reason for
this law
is uh maybe people are dying from those
drugs but there was no proof during the
testimony that anyone was killed by by
those synthetic cannabinoids in New
Hampshire so uh I I don't see an urgency
and uh I don't support the drug war so I
will vote against thank you thank you
representative Leon um thank you Mr
chairman um I had this amendment that I
had right now was just to try and
clarify some language and it wasn't
right that's why I didn't introduce it
but I had also sought to have an
amendment to push the sunsight out
another three years because we've been
waiting in the state to actually do
something about cannabis legalization
and this should continue to have the
option to be a carrot in order to
encourage the other body to finally
agree with us on some sensible
legalization and sensible policy um so I
I maybe we may end up coming with that
um time period um where we would just be
extending the sunset further out so that
we can keep the conversation going but
I'll leave that to the floor I just I'm
not going to support the a to pass
because um I'm not quite convinced that
the other body is uh working in the same
spirit that we came to this agreement
representative mlan and then
representative Nagel yeah I mean and and
on that line because I I'd spoken with
representative lean about that I mean I
was really moved by uh the testimony by
Mr Simon about you know the impact of
these cannaboids um and so I don't like
them but you know I'm hearing a lot of
stuff in the news with respect to how
the Senate is maybe positioning itself
with respect to our legislation and so
we're talking about well we're going to
make cannabis legal and all this stuff
but it's kind of almost putting the cart
before the horse so I was kind of in
support of keeping the prohibition in
place but basically having a a
three-year window to just kind of let
everything kind of settle out with that
unfortunately it it it came to me at the
last minute we didn't have time to make
it happen so could I maybe just get a a
straw poll Mr chair if we were to bring
forth a floor Amendment you know if we
ought to pass it today and we bring
forth a floor Amendment for the the
threee sunset would that be something
that that folks would maybe support
ought to pass it today and they a floor
Amendment for three years I just a straw
pull throwing it out
there representative
wber uh just a comment on that I think
if
um I wouldn't object to a three-year
Sunset but I think that if anybody here
thinks that the Senate is going to be
influenced in their views towards
legalization and I I share the
frustration of my colleague who has has
worked very hard on this um I don't
think whether we have a sunset in 3
years or whether we simply extend the
prohibition is going to have a blind bit
of difference over there because think
of all the incredibly strong incredibly
valuable work that has been done to meet
their needs and their
expectations and it has been unavailing
and I think that if all of those best
eff
on a hugely bipartisan basis in the
house uh with all of the input that
people have considered over months and
years and
decades um I don't think what we do on
this bill is going to have any
difference so um I'm I'm very
comfortable letting it go as a as a
straight
prohibition
um I I don't see why we would
spend the effort to do the three-year
but representative Nagel thank you Mr
chair I I just wanted to make two
comments first um um number one I'm
going to support the bill as is secondly
well the third three comments second one
is um you know we deal with a lot of
adverse reactions to drugs death is only
one of them there's plenty of others
that we need to worry about and the
third is kind of a prophecy that I
shared with my colleague earlier today
um I have this very entertaining poster
at home that was made in the 1950s that
shows a doctor between surgical cases
saying that he prefers Camel cigarettes
to everything else and the the reason
why I bring that up is I don't want to
sit here in 50 years and say that we
created the same mess with cannabis
which I personally believe we're on the
road to doing so I think the more we can
control these dangerous substances of
more highly addictive nature that will
have an adverse effect on our young
people the better and I think that's why
would there's a lot of thought needs to
go in this as we go forward so we don't
create another Public Health
crisis thank you all right um why don't
we do that STW poll um representative
profile uh thank you Mr chair so I I
guess I'm conflicted over this bill
because I on one hand I would like to
see us maximize freedom on the other
hand and I saw materials that showed
substances that were made to look like
packaging for candy and that really
bothers me furthermore uh a gentleman
came in here who
is his you know his mission is to
advance cannibalization
legalization and he said we are against
these things being legal so I am um I
I'm conflicted on this one but I tend to
want want to come down on what I see as
the safe side of this having said that I
would and and and I for me this the the
context of other legal
legalization conversations does not
impact my vote on this bill
um having having said all that I I'm I'm
inclined to support this and I would be
much more inclined to support it if it
had that
Amendment with a with a three-year
window okay representative palaz
a question to if we are doing a SL po
could somebody better explain what
amendment we are voting uh
getting thank you Mr chair no I was just
trying to to gauge the the temperature
of the committee representative poov as
to whether or not if we pass this ought
to pass and I was to bring a floor
amendment when we go into session for a
three-year Sunset if that's something
you know that the the that the folks on
the committee thought would have value
and would support when it came to the
floor could you explain what s s said
would mean inste of immediate right it
would be yeah so what happens is if we
don't if we don't pass this if we pass
this bill then the prohibition remains
if we don't pass the bill then I think
in July or whatever it is I forget the
time if we don't pass the bill then all
of a sudden this stuff comes back back
on the streets I don't want the stuff to
come back on the street um but
everything the whole discussion is in
flux so I just wanted to have a
three-year window to say guess what
we're going to keep the prohibition um
but instead of it being a forever
prohibition it would just be a
three-year prohibition and we could
evaluate things and come back uh either
with a repeal or a permanent prohibition
at that time um it just basically
instead of having a permanent
prohibition it just gives us a
three-year um that's all I was thinking
and just
or years so I'm not sure what the
prohibition
does do I need to repeat that for the
record yeah go ahead I said I'm not sure
what a three Re prohibition does because
you can't bind a future legislature so
future legislature could lift a
Prohibition or keep it or whatever
that's true of any law
right representative Weber I think we're
having this discussion because the
reason for this bill is there there was
a sunset
prior and that
Sunset of the prohibition is going to be
up in July of this year and we're all a
little uncomfortable about what happens
then or many of us are uncomfortable
about what happens then um so um but I
think that my feeling about a three-year
Sunset as a floor amendment is um I
wouldn't vote for it but if it passes I
would vote for the bill as amended but I
uh I probably wouldn't do a lot of work
I I think I think there are a lot of
things that I would
like to be out there before this stuff
this stuff seems to me to be the Wild
Wild West and I I really appreciate the
efforts to Define and regulate and and
keep things below a certain safe level
but there are so many things that we
could regulate better control better
this isn't one of them so I'm I'm really
very comfortable with the permanent
prohibition and if we learn different if
we come up with different language as
you say that can happen any one of the
next years representative not up
them I guess I'm in favor of three years
is better than nothing and in the three
years when things are legalized on both
sides of that you know whatever we've
got a little time to wiggle and in the
meantime we're keeping strange stuff
dressed up like candy off the counters
which I'm in favor of but if I may sure
but if we pass a Prohibition we pass a
Prohibition and we keep it off the
counters until that bill happens and
then that bill can legalize whatever
they want to legalize in a comprehensive
way so that's why I'm arguing for not
having to redo this every three years
representative Nel did you have your
hand up no
okay other
discussion okay I'm seeing no other
discussion representative mlan I I I
just think for for some people who are
like pure free market folks having a a
three-year Sunset out there it might be
something where they would say you know
I I'll go for that because I know at
least it's not forever so it's something
to kind of bring people together um
because I saw a lot with this thing if I
have a choice between octopath and
itl I'm octop pass um absolutely but you
know but there may be other folks that
there may be not and so this may be some
Middle Ground just thinking ahead and so
that's what that was why I asked for the
straw pole thank you Mr chair he do you
still want your straw pole
or yeah be okay okay I'll those in favor
of the three-year prohibition as a floor
Amendment looks like at least half the
committee right one
two okay all right go ahead if you want
to offer that then so yeah I mean I'm
just oh I'm sorry those
opposed about 5050 right
yeah so okay thank you Mr chair I think
maybe I'll there's enough interest that
maybe I'll I'll work something up and
the floor will dispose of it as it will
okay thank you
all right uh any other discussion on um
sp5 representative Lon um thank you Mr
chairman um I think that I'm going to
end up opposing this all to pass just
because I think that on the floor that
would be a better motion but um I
recognize we're all going to do what we
want to but I just wanted to let you
know
why anything anyone else any other
discussion all right that being said the
motion is out to pass on S sp505 I'll
ask the clerk to call the all
representative Leon
no Representative lelis
no clerk votes
yes representative copal yes
representative Clan
yes representative PL
no representative Melvin
no representative Nagel
yeah representative Palo no
representative Weber
yes representative McKay yes
representative fedus yes representative
Canon yes
yes representative
nutup representative Shapiro yes
representative Merchant yes
representative Murphy yes representative
Hammer
yes representative tez yes and
representative McDonald
yes 15 to five motion passes okay I
assume that's going to be Minority
Report or not sure if anyone wants to
write it before the calendar deadline
okay all right well representa I mean
you could write I mean there could be an
ought to pass report and an ought to
pass with Amendment report not not
without an not without an amendment
number okay got
it all right so we'll just go with uh
with the majority report then who Mr
chair representative Merchant who made
the motion to pass representative Weber
in second uh represent M okay thank
you anything else on S
sp505 okay say none okay with that I am
well no we will'll keep the executive
session open to consider these other
bills rep uh Miss D do you have that
side by side for
us and you do
the bottom two have already been before
the other three are just coming out of
committee oh okay so you can consider
the Amendments areed
IDE so there's a potential effect
more 1 all I did was um the amendment
because it's very short um it just adds
an inter report
okay great thank
you paperwork goes along with this that
I need to asked Karen if she didn't know
um well this is all I got we could get
copies for everyone but the side by side
we'll address it yeah and again we can
all have copies if if we need
there's a roll call or anything like
that I believe so no I think it's
just we we didn't do a roll call last
[Music]
year I was saying we don't normally take
roll calls we just sort do it
informally
yes sure
usually it's it's the end of the road
unless you really want to study it
unless you really have people studying
it now which I think is by exception so
you that again a report has to be
written by October 25th and it can be as
simple as uh not recommended for future
legislation I understand or it can be as
expensive as you want
so okay well we can we can put it
together then I like I can just
appointment you going to put like a sign
up cheat or something for those bills
or um that would be a a good way to
approach it um
Christina we have a could we get a list
of all the interm study bills yes I do
have one already
okay
okay I know I've already started one so
it
may we're getting information on other
potential bills that are coming back to
us
um these have not been acted on as yet
right Christina right the only there's
only two so far that have been acted on
and we need another copy of the
amendment uh for
1712 oh so this is a third bill that we
had had before yeah well the these
are the two bills we're going to talk
about today are 1303 and 160 9 these
others are potential ones that are going
to be coming back that we'll be ready to
have some background on if and when that
occurs we just try and look ahead of a
little bit and then 1712 that's one of
the that bill is is also um it looks
like an amendment that's been offered
over there um in the Senate and I they
haven't Christina they haven't acted
on which one ones are weed uh 13 uh 1303
and
16009 Christina they have enacted on
1712 right this this amendment's just in
like in the pipeline and they haven't
actually passed this yet or no so they
it
has
okay all right great thank
you okay so uh looking at the two bills
that we have formally gotten back and
the first one's actually a second
committee bill so uh representative
Janan with the ways and means will and
his group will be weighing in on it
after us but with the first committee uh
that was the one uh dealing with the
estate of teste B
Banu and um I'm uh the other body does
what the other body does I thought we
offered a good proposal a third a third
and a
third and they made it 40% 4 % and
20% so um I'll throw it up to open the
conversation I I don't have a problem
with what they did I don't know why they
did it but representative
Weber I have to say that um from from my
perspective alone I would just concur I
think the idea of going to a committee
of conference and then having the
possibility of somebody being cranky
with something completely
different uh doesn't make sense I think
all of this is a windfall and that we
ought to Concur and get it on its way
and get the money to the people who can
use it I I would agree with that um
representative uh
Murphy just a question that that I
didn't know the answer to Is does the
state or the people that run the estate
have an opinion about this or that would
be my question if they don't they ask
representative Weber oh on on the yeah
never mind I'm sorry no if if as long as
the state does not have a problem with
the the the change I would agree with
the fact that we should just concur they
didn't really weigh in on how they
wanted us to handle it um and the
department is fine with it but they were
just concerned about where it was going
to go how it was going to be handled and
this is consistent with the you know the
individual's wishes representative
Shapiro thank you Mr chairman I don't
see any reason to um non-c concur accept
annoyance and and I don't think we
should I don't think we should let that
be our primary motivation so I think we
should just concur is there any
objection to concurring on this
bill all right I'll I'll let the ways
and means folks know and that we want to
Concur and I suspect they all agree with
that okay next up is uh HB 1609 FN and
we have a side by side on that I I
believe it's pretty
um minimal change but
I can speak to that please sure
representative Murphy I presented this
to we passed this bill uh initially back
um
whenever and the amendment that I worked
with um representative krishman on uh
wanted to include direct Primary Care
provider the one that we picked was the
New England direct Primary Care
Alliance subsequent to our passage of
the bill we realized that that group
does not look favorably upon nursing
care for and include nurses as part of
their Primary Care um uh initiative so
we found direct Primary Care Frontier
which is a New England New Hampshire
based that actually has nurse
practitioners and it basically allows
for nurses to participate in the primary
care so what we did is between the time
when we passed it unanimously to when I
presented this to the committee uh HHS
at in the
body uh we gave him this amendment to
basically change the name of the um
direct primary care that we would
utilize going forward and they were
agreeable to that they voted 5 zero I
think it
was you have any thoughts about about
what action we should take I I would
definitely concur because it was it's
consistent with what we all uh agreed to
going forward representative kushman and
myself both agreed that having direct
Primary Care Frontier as a New Hampshire
based uh Direct Care um that also
recognized nursing and nurse
practitioners specifically in the care
of their patients was important to us so
we both agreed to that as well okay
thank you y
representative Nagel thank you Mr chair
this is a question for the
representative um doctor they so when
you say nursing I just want to make sure
I understand nurse and nurse
practitioner or just nurse
practitioner thanks for the question uh
they the New England direct primary cure
Alliance within the Cadre of you know
providers does not include nurse
practitioners that's okay that's what
whereas the direct Primary Care Frontier
which is in New base does include nurse
practitioners as part of their Primary
Care model um and representative kushman
felt very sensitive to the fact that
they were uh that the New England direct
Primary Care Alliance was specifically
excluding nursing Personnel in their
Primary Care uh practice can I ask one
more question go ahead in in the in
interest of being bruised and battered
over some other issue um does this also
include Physicians Assistance or
not uh is that irrelevant I think that's
irrelevant I think that they are
included but because they work under the
license of a physician they can be part
of their Primary Care team um so this
was a amendment that we had asked for
and it was introduced to the Senate but
subsequent to our passage unanimously in
this body um as it was originally
written representative per and then
representative TZ thank you Mr chairman
I'm just curious I don't have any
problem with this change but I'm just
curious is the are the other members of
this commission um identified as
individuals or as part of a specific
practice or representative of a certain
group of practitioners I'm just
wondering why this is so
specific as opposed to a representative
of
um direct primary care right I I I agree
um the majority of the people and I
counted them out I think there's about
21 that are on this commission uh and
this is the commission that was
established back in 200 and 10 I believe
it was uh on the commission of the
interdisciplinary Primary Care
Workforce I'm on their committee as a
representative of the body of the the
house but there is also um and I'll read
to you the medical society appointed by
Society uh Dental Society appointed by
the society so the great majority are
appointed but there are you know
exceptions to that what was specifically
noted was that we wanted to pursue a
representative from the primary care the
direct Primary Care those the 24-hour
you know you know shops you see on the
side of the road you know direct primary
care you don't have to have a primary
care for provider you
basically um go in there get your
primary care issue addressed and go home
but you don't have a specific tie to
these people um and so we wanted to have
a direct primary care
provider uh as one of the
21 um Representatives you know on this
commission uh the only and we passed
that initially like I said
unanimously um it was subsequent to that
and this was not initiated by this the
other body this was initiated by myself
and representative kushman that we would
we recognize that New England direct
Primary Care Alliance does not have
nurse practitioners but that the direct
Primary Care Frontier which is at New
Hampshire based um uh organization does
have within
their um primary care providers nurse
practitioners and we thought that was
important Paul
so I I would just say that um my vote if
we're taking a vote would be to concur
although I think it's a little
problematic to have a specific practice
what if the practice goes out of
business but um but I guess that could
be addressed when they go out of
business if they go out of business and
that'll also say something about direct
Primary Care perhaps so um I think we
should just concur I I think it's um
close enough and better than what we
what the way it left this committee
representative TZ yeah just uh as a
response to the questions the first
thing is there is no direct Primary Care
Association in the State uh there's the
two practices I spoke yesterday to the
chair of the commission because we were
in a meeting together um and so she
expressed you know she explained to me
what representative Murphy already
explained about the why and the other
thing is just to clarify direct Primary
Care is when um there's no insurance
it's direct between a patient paying a
provider directly some people might
think of it as concierge um it's a new
model of practicing and my objection
originally was similar to yours where it
should be an association and not a
particular business but I think we've
gotten to the best place we can and I'll
also Concur and if I could just address
that thank you uh direct Primary Care is
a new C model and so it would be very
difficult to just basically say the
direct primary care of whatever state or
whatever County or whatever you know
group of states you live within you know
New England say so it was important to
at least have the direct primary care
that was part of New Hampshire the only
one that's part of New Hampshire be
representative on the board or on this
commission so he chose them but you're
absolutely right that once it becomes a
body that is more formally established
um perhaps then you could just say um as
with the other ones you know appointed
by the Association appointed by the
governor appointed by the
society but I would I would definitely
concur because we actually
representative krishman and myself were
the ones that asked them to introduce
this amendment representative
M you Mr chairman if I'm correct the
Senate just changed one thing in this in
our bill and that was the go from New
England direct primary to direct primary
care and I I don't think it's our job to
reconsider this whole
legislation we're we're saying do we
agree with the Senate I agree and I
think we should get on with
it thank you any other
discussion uh so is the sense of the
committee to concur then on
16009 okay
great all right those are the only two
we have actually gotten back again
there's five pending my thought is and
I've confirmed this with the clerk and
and with the representative Weber if we
when we get others back if so me they
don't kill them all uh I know they're
killing a lot of house bills over there
but um we can you know representative
Weber and I can confer and then confer
with our respective caucuses and come up
to it with a decision that way rather
than in the interests of time and
people's schedules rather than have
everybody come back for a quick meeting
yes by caucus right by caucus right
there won't be a formal meeting but
it'll be another a sense of the
committee representative
Weber as this is our is this is our last
meeting for the session I just wanted to
thank you Mr chairman for your
leadership and for the way in which you
have run this committee um I I think
that an example has been set of how to
disagree very
vigorously but to still maintain a
certain degree of decorum and
collegiality and I very much appreciate
it and I want to thank all of my
colleagues for uh making that possible
so thank you all thank you
representative Weber representative Leon
um thank you Mr chairman and I kind of
feel bad bringing up a technical matter
after such a wonderful statement to the
committee and I do want to thank my
colleagues um everybody here for the
same and having such a great committee
on house bill
1568 um they've amended it to what um so
far coming out of committee they have
the language of Senate Bill 409 as it
passed the Senate however we in this
committee amended Senate Bill 409
because there were the conflicting
language about the response of a of a
911 call and whatnot um so I think that
we perhaps may want to also consider
that in combination with Senate Bill 409
as it passed out of our committee
because that is also a house position um
so I just wanted to bring everybody's
attention to
that um on the bill that that um we had
here for the for the potential
concurrent should they pass it is House
Bill 1568 the relative to Medicaid
reimbursement for non-transport
emergency medical service calls um they
had changed the language to Senate Bill
409 as they sent to us but they did not
include the amendment that this
committee passed um in that language and
I don't believe um it at least in the
work sessions Finance did not further
change that bill um so assuming that
nothing unexpected happened yesterday in
finance they passed it with the same
language that this committee had so I
don't so the question would be if how we
proceed should that other language
pass they not making a formal
recommendation just raising a concern I
yes I'm just raising a concern and that
we should also draw that Paraline with
parallel with Senate Bill 409 personally
if they if we pass 409 um especially if
they accept it I think it's the superior
language because we changed it from what
they will be amending
to nor has uh Senate Bill 409 passed the
Full House finally but we should know
that those two are parallel
bills I think Christina Dyer has some
information on this
not
left as long as you pass Bill you're
right yes I agree with you on that part
of but what I'm saying is
that
legisl
de yeah Christina will be updating us as
they do pass the U the full Senate and
so that we can we can take them up and
act yeah okay um
anything else on these bills Mr chair
yes representative PL I just want to say
this was an excruciating amount of
work well and I wanted to say I'm
appreciative of sitting on the last day
of your committee I'd like to see how uh
different committees works I got a a
Peak at HH SN e so thank you EA EA
right well again following up on
representative Weber I appreciate um you
the opportunity to work with her and and
learn from eight terms is it you've been
I think I was reading about it eight
learn from her experience um is no
substitute for experience and she
certainly uh former um speaker Pro
committee chairman how many other titles
have you
had but anyway I do appreciate her
guidance and her her advice throughout
this these two years and certainly
appreciate the vice chairman she had to
fill in probably more than she should
have had to fill in because of some
medical issues I had last year but thank
you representative Lon for that and
thank all of you I think we we've done a
lot of good stuff I think we've uh the
number of bills for a committee that
deals with some of the controversial
stuff we deal with to have as many on
consent as we have had I think is
commendable and really shows an effort
that we want to work together and we did
work together so again thank you all um
we'll be seeing each other on the floor
of the house um I think most of are
probably running again but one never
knows what the voters are going to
decide so whether we see each other next
year or not but but we will be seeing
each other in the next several weeks so
again thank you all anything else before
we conclude representative Nagel
the uh representative uh Christina you g
to send a list out
right no representative
Weber if we have meetings on them uh
they have to be done in person because
we don't do anything on Zoom um and what
comes out of those meetings is either
recommended for further legislation or
not recommended for further legislation
and an explanation we just write a
report that goes in the house calendar
and we will all get together uh one more
time to vote on those uh so that will be
a regular sort of committee meeting but
all we can vote on is recommended for
further legislation or not we don't have
to have the legislation drafted and it
doesn't bind anybody in the next
legislature to either introduce or not
introduce it's just a discussion wasn't
what I so if we decide to create an
interim study committee we can do that
by email and then oh absolutely and and
the chair can just do that by
circulating well yeah well I'll I'll
send out an email once we once I have
the exact bills and uh you know solicit
interest and then we'll see where we go
from there so there's no
party next
September we we'll meet we'll meet again
in the fall I would imagine probably
early October um representative lels yes
as a sub I'm not necessarily privy to
everything that goes on but I was
promised a beer bash or a a
p uh well that question needs to be
directed to the person who promised you
to be a I know it wasn't me thank you Mr
chairman thank you you thank you and
thank all of the uh those uh who who
substituted today we appreciate your
participation and your
help anyone else anything
else okay without that we stand
adjourned
oh aren't you looking official
the only I get
nervous for